let's start with those bathroom laws
sure you have north carolina's saying
it's going to sue the US government
Department of Justice saying it's going
to sue North Carolina you've said the
Texas is going to fight this how a
similar lawsuit well we're going to
fight it the same way that I had been
fighting against the Obama
administration I think I hold the record
for suing the Obama administration i
sued 31 times in my capacity as the
Attorney General before I became
governor I talked about this issue in my
new book broken but unbowed it's the
issue about how the Constitution and the
federal government has been turned
upside down here's what happened
Congress has taken several opportunities
to weigh in on the transgender bathroom
issue whether or not should be a part of
tunnel nine whether or not should be
part of the Civil Rights Act and each
time Congress voted against it
the Obama administration said Congress
you had a chance to do your job you
didn't do it we're going to do it that
strips the Constitution of what it was
intended to do is the lawmakers Congress
who have the authority under the
Constitution to make the law not the
president and what the president is
doing now is making law not executing it
so it's your opposition to this about
the legal overreach or is it about the
issue itself are you opposed to
transgender people selecting which
bathroom they use or is about the way
the government's gone about doing it
well actually it's both but to be clear
the the real issue here and the bigger
issue that is wrecking America is the
way the Obama administration is
rewriting the Constitution by rewriting
the law which it does not have the power
to do you refer to President Obama as a
king in this book you take issue with
his tactics as he mentioned you've sued
the federal government many times before
we had a decision from the Supreme Court
today related to Obamacare I know you
were at the front of suing the federal
government over the Affordable Care Act
to begin with what's your reaction to
how that decision came down today in
effect saying we're kicking this back
down to the lower courts to sort the
sound first so you'll know my reference
to Obama as a king comes from his lips
himself when he said 20 times he would
be acting as a king as an emperor that
he had no authority to rewrite the
immigration laws and then he rewrote the
immigration laws and so I'm using his
own self descriptor when it comes to
rewriting the laws which is what he's
been doing as it concerns today's
decision obviously it's a good
for the Little Sisters of the Poor it's
ludicrous to expect the Little Sisters
of the Poor to provide abortion related
drugs for their employees that is not
what the law was intended to do nor
should Americans be coerced into
providing products that violate their
religious beliefs